So two of the things that you pointed out as a programming choices, one,
was that anything with Donald Trump or response to Donald Trump rated better?
And so, uh, you,
or D just every about every cable news outlet covered everything Trump did,
um, during his 2016 run. And then that became true,
obviously when he was president. Um,
and then the inverse of that was that if there was something kind of educational
or scientific, uh,
or deeper than it would be less appealing or wouldn't rate
as well. And so you wound up wound up with like a bias towards, uh,
Trump all the time and less about, for example,
what a public health official or scientist was saying.
Mm yeah. Yeah. Um,
and initially when the pandemic started,
they are professional journalists and they kicked into gear just like they
should. And they were trying to get the information they could from
scientists and doctors and frontline workers, and,
um, developed a special, um,
Dr. Zika manual was, you know, on once a week, um, to,
to cover, you know, focus on issues related to COVID.
And after a number of weeks, they discovered that that wasn't writing well.
So then it got kind of, you know, started on Monday, Tuesday,
and then they pushed it to a Friday.
Cause that's the day that they don't care as much about ratings because that's
for our own programming for MSNBC's or less words,
programming needs, that, that it wasn't as important.
And then it slowly just kind of fizzled out and died. Um,
and it was because it wasn't writing well. And,
and then you could see the coverage when they were,
would do a COVID segment. It really was about just the politics.
Um, and they would have on science reporters or correspondents,
but they were, you know, pushing them,
trying to get them to talk more about the politics and the actual science.
And it was through a time when there were a lot there. I mean,
there's still lots of information coming out all the time about the,
about the virus and vaccines and what we know and what we don't know,
and that all of that was, you know,
they would try to get to it if they could, or it just,
wasn't kind of the top line. It was something that was thrown in maybe as a,
you know, an afterthought, um,
that all of that information really got pushed to the wayside and they focused
much more on the politics. And it was, you know, the, uh,
Trump attacking the blue state governors, or, you know, what Trump,
you know, what dumb thing Trump said or didn't say, or didn't do. Um,
it really focused on that.
And I understand that there's a time and a place for that,
but it was just dominated everything.
That drove me crazy on the trail to where it was always like
Trump's stupid or inflammatory comment of the day. And then even like,
I'd running for president and I were in New Hampshire and they'd be like,
Trump said this, what do you think of that? And I'm just like,
are you kidding me? Like really? Yeah.
And yeah, yeah. W it, that, um,
that same idea was pervasive throughout the, you know,
it was last election cycle as well. Um, the democratic primary process,
you know,
if there was a personality dispute that got way more attention than any
interesting policy conversation.
And I think there were lots of interesting policy conversations we could have
had, you know, um, the ideas that you had being the start of it.
Um, uh, but then, you know,
when it came down to the general and it was Biden versus Trump and, you know,
every, almost every single I know that they tried to, to,
to focus on Biden, um, when they could,
but it always turned into a segment about Trump. You know,
they don't want to talk about anything that is negative towards Democrats,
cause that was bad for the MSNBC audience and the same thing, you know,
applied to the democratic primaries as well. He don't, there just,
wasn't a full discussion that ultimately benefits everyone. So.
I might have been part of that or a non part of that.
Yeah. I know. I know. I,
this is not exactly an unbiased audience I'm talking to right now.
Yeah, no, no. I mean, again, like this, this to me is more of like a systemic,
um, uh, fraud problem.
And, and it, uh, yeah, I saw it happen. I've watched it in 2016. And so that,
you know, when everybody was, I'm sorry, um,
everyone was shocked that Hillary didn't do better than she did. I,
I was frustrated cause I was like, no, there were,
there were pulling numbers out that showed, you know, enthusiasm for her,
you know, that were concerning. And you know,
that MSNBC wasn't covering that.
So that liberal audience didn't necessarily, you know.
Well, that's rough, you know,
like that there were actually some numbers that cut the other way that weren't
covered. I mean, that's, that's actually new to me relatively speaking.
Maybe everyone knows that already.
I was angry almost every day in those meetings through,
and it, it did,
it was not pleasant because I, I was at a point where I, I,
I, I mean, I never really bite my tongue anyway, but I,
I just could not believe that they were making decisions about, you know,
economic policy segments and, Oh, that's not going to,
you might not the day that I gave my resignation,
they canceled an economic segment because quota wasn't going to rate and they
filled it with some other like, um, you know,
not a serious segment. And, um,
I, you know,
between the pandemic and I Al I frankly had issues with how they were
covering the George Floyd stuff. Um, the, the protests,
uh, again, you know,
the way that they covered the protest, they,
they wanted conflict and they put the correspondence on
the ground in a way that they, they, even if nothing was happening,
they wanted it to seem like something was happening.
And if there was a car that was on fire,
they're going to play that video over and over again. Meanwhile,
95% of the protests were peaceful,
but I've been in the control room going back to 2015 and the black lives
matters protest, then people, um,
they would monitor all of those protests, they'd have cameras and choppers,
you know, they are monitoring the protest and in less,
it turned violent. They would not quote, take it live. You know, they,
they wouldn't show that peaceful protest because nothing was happening according
to them, you know, it was, it was boring and it wouldn't make good TV.
So that, um,
that is a type of thing that kind of got to me, um,
through the George Floyd, um, coverage, uh, there were,
there were other elements, there were, there were, um, points about the,
uh, election and election security.
Those stories kept getting sidelined. They were not covering them. They'd,
you know, I was trying to get them to cover the issues, you know, how,
how are you going to have a safe election, you know, with COVID and, you know,
there were lots of groups working on it and they, um, uh, it was really, really,
really difficult to get them to cover that. Um, uh,
there was, uh,
there were opportunities, um, when Trump went to Tulsa there opportunities to,
to talk about some of the kind of painful history in this country.
Um, it was, would have been very easy to discuss, um,
the history and Tulsa and the Tulsa riots or Juneteenth,
and what is all behind, you know,
what is behind that and why it's so meaningful to the African-American
community.
And you can trace the anger from those events to George Floyd. It,
it would have been, it wouldn't have taken very long at all, but there were,
there was, there was, um, a history there that I didn't know,
and I know a lot of smart people and journalists didn't know,
and it was a perfect opportunity to, to share that.
And it helps the nation understand, you know,
what is happening other than just, you know,
people are angry and looting the local Walmarts.
One thing that a producer friend of yours said that really, um, seemed telling,
was, look, people come to us for comfort. Like they don't see us as the news.
Uh, I thought that was incredible. And there is something fundamental about, uh,
two different purposes. One would be, I'm going to Edify and inform.
And so I'm going to serve you some stuff that might be not that scintillating.
It might be kind of boring. It's like broccoli as programming.
And then this other direction that it's like, I'm entertainment.
Like I'm going to have a certain patter and rhythm and
characters and something that you can cheer.
Right? Yeah. And that was in one of our, uh, uh,
planning meetings. So that was a senior producer. And, um,
it's definitely something that, you know,
stood out and something I remembered because you're abdicating your role as a
journalist. And that's,
it's confusing because otherwise it kind of looks like a newscast. You know,
you have an anchor sitting at a desk with, you know, you know,
the TV over his shoulder and you're covering things that are in the news.
And so the audience, uh, you know, I realized that, you know, they, there's,
there's an awareness and MSNBC is, um, uh,
more opinionated than the straight, you know, 6:00 PM newscast.
But at the same time, they're, they,
they play it both ways.
So that's what I think is really dangerous when it looks like something that
should be reliable, but it,
it isn't really then that's that's to me where the problem
comes in.
I'm pretty sure news is in the name somewhere,
you know, like there's subway in there. Like, there's the word news.
Thank you for listening in. I hope you enjoyed this conversation. If you did,
please do subscribe to yang,
speaks and click on notifications so we can let you know,
every time we have a new episode.